[Music]
florida governor ron desantis calling
arrests for mass
mandate violations in overreach by local
governments
as he is now pardoning floridians
punished for covet 19 violations
here now to react is florida lieutenant
governor jeannette nunez janette thank
you so much for being here this morning
makes sense to me so pardons to folks
who were cracked down upon
for covet violations
well good morning pete it's an honor to
be here with you this morning and
and really what we've seen is governor
desantis systematically chiseling away
at local government overreach largesse
and really what i believe were draconian
measures passed upon floridians and so
the governor
wasn't content to let these civil and
criminal penalties
continue so he issued a full categorical
pardon
when you have people that could
potentially be serving jail time for
violating a masked mandate
that's something that we weren't allowed
we weren't going to allow to happen
well i know personally in other states
gym owners salon owners and others who
are still
suffering under the weight of penalties
and fees potential criminality
so you're saying with this move if there
were health inspections or someone
wearing a mask where they shouldn't have
that that ordeal for them is over indeed
and what i would tell those people from
other states that are suffering under
the weight of these local government
mandates and state mandates
come on down to florida we're open we're
free and we're booming
what was the key you know it was an
executive order in september of 2020
that the
the governor there signed uh opening all
florida businesses regardless of local
restrictions
what gave him and and you guys the
ability to foresee
how important that would be for people
well governor desantis throughout the
pandemic
understood that we needed to balance the
health and well-being of floridians
but also make decisions that were going
to empower floridians
and make decisions on their own allow
businesses to operate allow people to go
to work we weren't in the business of
deeming
whose job was essential or whose
business was essential and whose wasn't
so governor desantis contrary to the
critics and the pundits and the liberal
elites and the corporate media
he made decisions based on actual
science which is why you saw him
eliminating certain restrictions which
is why you saw him opening up schools so
that parents could send their kids to
get a quality education
so at the end of the day when people
want to criticize i think the outcomes
are clear the evidence is out and
governor desantis has been a leader
in managing the pandemic and making sure
that floridians
were put first yeah the courage of
leaders is exposed in the most critical
moments especially when the chorus is
saying something else and they decide to
go against it
and on the side of average people and
common sense and governor desantis has
certainly done that
jeannette nunez thank you so much for
your time we appreciate